Oh Bist du bereit? Bist du bereit? Wir gehen ins On in drei, zwei. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Das Podcast Ofo. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und gegenüber von mir ist Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast Ofo. Mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan Tietze. Tietze, hallo, guten Tag. Diese berühmte Folge 25, wo man weiss, wo man nicht weiss. Ist das jetzt schon irgendwie Porzellanhochzeit oder irgendein Jubiläum oder eines dieser völligen Scheiss-Egal-Jubiläen, die wir zahlen können irgendwie, irgendwie? Ja, ich glaube schon. Das nennt man, glaube ich, Graue, Korallenhochzeit, Post-it-Hochzeit, Unterwasser, Wild-West-Hochzeit oder so. Bist du eigentlich so ein Typ, der sich dann irgendwie so eine Themenhochzeit aussuchen würde? Weil du bist ja ein Fun-Guy, ne? Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß. Bist du dann auch jemand, der sagt, der das komplett durchzieht und sagt so, auf meiner Beerdigung will ich, dass nochmal irgendwie die Ch Chippendales auftauchen und die Golden Girls, alle die überlebt haben, und nochmal richtig einen vom Latz ziehen. Ja, ich bin auch einer, der so ganz krasse Wünsche hätte, irgendwie, dass der Ring von der Schildkröte reingebracht wird. Dass dann ewig dauert, wie er vorgetragen wird. Die ersten zwei Meter lachen die Leute noch, die nächsten Meter dann nicht mehr. Nach Stunde acht ist Oma schon irgendwie eingeschlafen, das dritte Mal, die ersten gehen schon, ja, das ist, aber das sind diese Sachen, die es dann ein bisschen brisant macht, nur ein bisschen, da erzählt man sich noch in zehn Jahren von, einfach weil man noch in zehn Jahren da sitzt und auf die Schildkröte wartet. Aber das ist doch der einzige Grund, warum man das macht mit diesem Ringtragen, um ein bisschen Spannung reinzubringen. Wer auch immer die Idee hatte, wir bringen den Ring von einem kleinen Kind, lassen wir den reinbringen, einfach um zu sehen, fällt das Kind um, verliert es den Ring, isst es den Ring, während es da vorläuft, einfach um ein bisschen Spannung reinzubringen, um damit nicht alles so rituell voraus abläuft. Ich finde aber, das ist komplett ein total spannungsgeladener Moment, auch die Fragen, die man dann stellt. Wollen Sie, dann nochmal den ganzen Namen sagen, den hier Anwesenden nochmal den ganzen Namen sagen, wenn man den ganzen Namen noch Zeit hat, nachzudenken? Ja, genau. Deswegen habe ich auch zwei zweite Namen. Mannnehmen. Und dann noch dieser spannungsgeladene Moment. Nein! Nochmal! Nein! Genau. Das sind diese Momente, wo man dann noch Zeit hat, sein Leben, wenn man sich vorbeirasen sieht. Das ist schon das dritte Mal, Rebecca. Ich will nicht. Nein! Nein! Was glaubst du, ist das Lustigste, was jemals auf diese Frage geantwortet wurde? Wollen Sie den hier Anwesenden heiraten? Ich glaube eher, können Sie die Frage wiederholen. Genau. Wir waren gerade auf Tinder, sorry. Was war das nochmal? Ja, genau. Sehr gut. Sehr gut, heute wollen wir. Wir sind ja auch jetzt irgendwie schon aus irgendeinem Grundsatz bei Hochzeiten gelandet, ist ja im weitesten Sinne auch das, worüber wir sprechen wollten. Wir wollten, also du wolltest, ich habe mich dazu vorbereitet, keine Ahnung, ich hoffe, dass ich irgendwie durch die Folge komme.
Geil, wenn ein Thema so eingeleitet wird, dass man sofort sagt, okay, wenn es nichts wird, ist deine Schuld.
Nee, es war ein Doppelthema. Wir hatten heute wieder so ein bisschen so eine Folge, wo wir uns nicht auf ein Thema einigen konnten.
Ja.
Weil es läuft bei uns immer ab, so hey, welches Thema sollen wir machen?
Dann bringt jeder fünf Vorschläge und dann einfach acht Stunden lang hören wir nichts von einander. Aber diese Vorschläge sind auch nie ernst gemeint oder wirklich recherchiert oder so, das sind einfach nur Vorschläge, was gerade in meinem Raum liegt, in meinem Radius, schlage ich einfach vor, so Schokobongs, Pinnwand, Lampe, Cappy, signiertes Bild von Julia Krüger, Joyce-Moderatorin, ist das vielleicht ein Thema, Marsband, Marsriegel, sowas. Und dann fünf Minuten vor Aufnahme, ja, was sollen wir machen? Und dann scrollen wir alle noch mal hoch, um diese acht Vorschläge zu sehen. Ja, nehmen wir halt Kinder und Trends. Machen wir Kinder, Trends und es ist mies mal halt irgendwas. Trends, apropos, da sind wir schon bei unserer ersten Rubrik. Titze, teste Trends. Nee, das habe ich jetzt nicht vorbereitet.
Ich dachte auch mehr, dass wir eine geistere Rubrik vielleicht. Das ist auch so, ich weiss auch
bei unseren, wenn wir mal irgendwann, wenn wir mal
schreiben oder so, wenn wir uns auf dem Podcast irgendwie einigen, wann kann es zu flühen, wenn man diese Konversationen hat, Ich habe noch nie geschrieben.
Ich weiss nie, was wir ernst meinen und was nicht.
Ich weiss selber auch nicht, was ich schreibe, ob ich das ernst meine oder nicht.
Das ist immer so ein Schwebezustand, so eine Schwebekonversation. So halb zwischen ernst, halb zwischen komplett wahnsinnig. Und ich weiss nie genau, mache ich das jetzt, was ich ja eben vorgeschlagen habe, oder habe ich das überhaupt ernst gemeint? Ja, ich komme um acht vorbei, haha. Und dann soll man wirklich um acht vorbeikommen oder nicht? Außer aus Spaß. Und dann meintest du, ja, wir machen auch eine neue Rubrik, Tizetress testet Trends, aber … Das war durchaus ernst gemeint. Ich habe mir ein paar Trends vorbereitet für dich. Und du sollst sie jetzt mal testen und sagen, ob die was für dich sind. Ich kann die bis zur nächsten Woche mal testen gerne. Ich habe nämlich diese Woche auch einen Trend ausgetestet. Also in Amerika zum Beispiel ist es ja so, dass … Also es gibt ja immer so gewisse Archetypen und gewisse Stereotypen und gewisse Archetypen. Es gibt auch Archenoa. Okay, hast du jetzt vorweggegriffen oder was? Was? Nein. Wusstest du, dass ich Archetypen sagen werde? Nein. Ich finde, Noah war ja der erste wirkliche Archetyp eigentlich. Achso. Ja, das ist natürlich der bessere Gag, aber den hast du dir vorbereitet. Warte mal, soll ich den, der gefällt mir echt gut, soll ich den raushauen? Ja, hau mal raus. Aber kommt mir schon ein bisschen bekannt vor, ich glaube. Gib's doch zu, das war so ein richtiger Florentin-Will-Gag, den er sich am Schreibtisch ausgesagt hat. Mit so einem Reagenzglas in der Hand hat er sich getestet. Mit dem großen Gaglexik. Und dann hat er so eine große Excel-Tabelle, wo er dann irgendwie mit seinem Taschenrechner ausgerechnet hat, was die optimale Gleichung ist. Und dann kam er raus. Noah war doch der Archetyp. Ja, hauen raus, mal gucken, was es gibt. Aber Moment mal, Noah war einfach nur, Noah war der erste Archetyp, oder was? Noah war doch der erste Archetyp, oder Leute? Community-Einbindung, einfach immer per se, einfach mal raushauen. Wir wollen ja heute... Schreibt's in die Kommentare, kannst du aber bei Twitter schreiben, habe ich auch so noch nicht gesehen. Wir wollen ja heute... Entschuldige, jetzt bin ich völlig raus. Wir wollten heute ja eigentlich auch mal Tweets konstruieren, und zwar als sich jeder von uns drei Jax überlegt, wollen wir die jetzt schon raushauen? Waren wir das schon nötig eigentlich? Ich dachte, das wäre so eine Rubrik, die wir einbauen, wenn wir schwimmen. Was ich so erwartet hätte bei Minute fünfunddreißig, vielleicht. Wir haben jetzt Minute sechs.
Wollen wir das jetzt schon machen?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich kann noch ein paar Sachen raushauen.
Keine Sorge.
Ich habe auch noch ein paar Sachen.
Und zwar habe ich Kritik bekommen tatsächlich zum Podcast.
Und ich dachte, dass ich die jetzt vielleicht mal anbringen kann, damit wir da direkt darauf eingehen können,
vielleicht diese 25. Folge einfach ein bisschen besser machen können.
Und zwar habe ich mit einer ...
Wir haben jetzt auch ein Viertel geschafft von 100.
Genau. Danach können wir nicht mehr machen, weil wir technisch ... Kurzer Mathematics-Fact. Vielen Dank für diesen Math-Fact. Ist das eine neue Rubrik vielleicht? Math-Fact? Math-Fact. Math-Fact-Tize. Math-Fact. Crystal Math. Auf jeden Fall habe ich Kritik bekommen. Und zwar habe ich mit einer Hörerin gesprochen, die meinte, ja, da habe ich euren Podcast gehört, aber da habe ich zur gleichen Zeit ein Knäckebrot gegessen und es war so laut, dass ich den Podcast gar nicht mehr gehört habe. Dankeschön, erstmal danke fürs Feedback, muss man erstmal sagen, glaube ich, sonst kommt man unhöflich rüber. Erstmal danke fürs Feedback. Genau, vielen Dank, dass du uns darauf hingewiesen hast, wir werden in Zukunft darauf achten. Also, wir werden folgendes lauter sprechen und Pausen machen zum Kauen eines Knäckebrots. Also, wenn man Dinge essen kann, die so laut beim Essen sind, dass man nichts mehr drumherum hören kann. Aber auch nicht, ist pausiert oder so, einfach akzeptiert, dass man die letzten zehn Sekunden nicht verstanden hat. Ja, ich muss einfach was essen. Naja. Ja, sehr gut. Wow, das hat jetzt 30 Sekunden gefüllt, hau rein. Es ist einiges, warte mal, ich muss kurz was öffnen. Ich kann nicht nachdenken und was öffnen und reden. Wir haben ja übrigens gerade eine Message bekommen. Ja, ne, ich öffne gerade ein Tweetdeck, weil wir haben echt tolles Feedback bekommen. Unsere Community ist mittlerweile richtig am Start, überall. Und zwar, schreiben Leute, Themenvorschlag, wie wäre die Welt heute, wenn Edmund Stoiber 2002 Kanzler geworden wäre?
Ja, das ist halt jetzt wieder so Realsatire.
Ich würde es gerne mal vorschlagen, das passt irgendwie auch nicht zu uns, aber ich würde es gerne mal vorlesen, wie ich gelernt habe beim Sprechtraining.
Themenvorschlag Wie wäre die Welt heute, wenn Edmund Stoiber 2002 Kanzler geworden wäre? Wirklich so, liest du? Tatsächlich, so muss man lesen, wenn man... Geworden wäre. Geworden wäre. Geworden wäre. Nee, keine Pause. Geworden wäre. Geworden wäre. Geworden wäre. Themenvorschlag. Vorschlag. Themenvorschlag. Wie wäre die Welt heute, wenn Edmund Stoiber 2002 Kanzler geworden wäre? Edmund, also beim D vorne S würde ich das nicht sprechen. Also Edmund Stoiber, nicht Edmund Stoiber, sondern Edmund Stoiber. Edmund Stoiber. Ja, Stoiber. Und damit du dann als Navigationssystem arbeiten kannst, oder was ist der Sinn dahinter? Themenvorschlag, wie wäre die Welt heute, wenn wir links abgebogen wären? Bitte wenden. Wenden. Das ist doch nicht wenden, Leute. Also wenn du mir irgendwann wenden vorlesen müsst. Leute, bitte, ne? Watch out. Ich rede mich immer so auf. Es heißt nicht wenden, es heißt wenden. Es heißt auch sollen. Das ist wieder so eine Pedanterie-Scheisse. Das ist das Schlimmste, wenn Leute was Neues lernen und einfach dieses neu gewonnene Wissen sofort dazu benutzen, anderen Leuten auf die Nerven zu gehen. Das heißt nicht, es macht Sinn, sondern es ergibt Sinn. Das ist ja der Alltag schon lange Diskussion geführt, weil das auch einfach Schwachsinn ist. Ja, aber Sprechen ist schon gut. Aber Sprechen ist ja auch was anderes als Lesen. Ich meine, Vorlesen und Nachrichtensprecher zu sein ist ja auch was ganz anderes, als einfach öffentlich mit jemandem zu sprechen. Da achtest du ja auf sowas gar nicht. Aber trotzdem, wenn du es als Kurs hast, dann achtest du plötzlich auf alles und fängst dann an, Leute zu verbessern, so ganz von oben herab. Aber das ist, glaube ich, normal. Das ist auch ein Trend, mein Trend persönlicher, mein ganz persönlicher Trend, Leute, korrigieren. Und was ist mit Arbeit, also wie spricht man? Arbeit. Arbeit. Arbeit. Arbeit, da hat man das guturale R noch mit drin. Ja, und meine Prüfungsaufgabe bestand halt darin, einen Text vorzulesen, und zwar geht er zwei Minuten dreissig lang. Und ist wieder zurück in der vierten Klasse. Ja, aber man fängt dann plötzlich, dann war ein Wort da drin, und zwar die Institution, in der wir beten. Wie würdest du es nennen? Kirche. So, und ich stand davor, heißt es jetzt, ist es lang, ist es relativ lang, heißt es Kirche oder Kirche, Kirche, Kirche, Kirche. Da habe ich da echt so eine Stunde vorgesessen, weil es mir einfach nicht einfallen wollte, weil es einfach für mich gar keinen Sinn gibt, gar keinen Unterschied macht. Aber dann muss man natürlich, muss ich nachfragen. Ich muss eine Mail schreiben, wie man Kirche ausspricht. Also diese Mail noch mal formulieren muss, hätte ich auch noch nie gedacht. Mama. Heißt es Kirche oder Kirche? Aber es ist tatsächlich Kirche. Kirche. Kirche, ja. Kirch, Kirch,ch. So wie Kneckebrot. Das ist etwas sehr Krachendes. Kneckebrot. Krach. Genau wie Krakau. Krakau. Krakau. Das habe ich mir gestern gedacht. Ich habe gestern einen Film geguckt mit Javier Badem. Ich finde, der hat auch so einen geilen Namen. Der ist so, wenn Badem in Krakau wohnt. Badem! Badem! Ja, das ist so, die Bildshumor. Ja, das mache ich tatsächlich. Badem! Das finde ich lustig. Badem und Krakau. Ja, finde ich lustig. Ah ja. Folgendes. Es gibt ja, also Trends, finde ich, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, du meinst es bestimmt eher, als das Thema vorgeschlagent, das meintest du wahrscheinlich eher so Trends im Sinne, was Gruppen machen oder was gerade in ist oder so. Aber ich finde, dass jeder seine persönlichen Trends hat, zum Beispiel. Ich interessiere mich, da habe ich immer schon sehr für Dinosaurier interessiert, so. Und die kamen ja jetzt, neuerdings plötzlich finden alle Jurassic World toll. Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier. Du musst aufpassen, dass sie dich nicht fressen. Genau, und jetzt neuerdings durch diesen Film sind anscheinend so viele Leute stehen auf Dinosaurier plötzlich, aus irgendeinem Grund, vielleicht weil es im Film thematisiert wird, so dass N24 und NTV plötzlich Dokumentationen zeigen. Und gestern habe ich mir dann eine Dokumentation darüber angeguckt, die kam dann irgendwie. Ich gucke mir das gerne an, weißt du, da kann man einfach mal ein bisschen entspannen. Ich finde, das ist so die einzige Sendung, wo man richtig entspannen kann, wo man nicht nachdenken muss. Man kriegt was erzählt von einem tollen Sprecher mit einer Sonorenstimme und hat semi-gut animierte Dinosaurier. Ihr Sprecher. Und ich muss sagen, gestern, diese Dokumentation hat wirklich alles kaputt gemacht, was ich jemals an Dinosauriern bewundert habe. Einfach wurde alles kaputt gemacht. Und zwar, es war so eine Dokumentation, die einem wirklich zeigen wollte, wie toll diese Welt ist. Im Prinzip hat sie aber ausgesagt, Herr, der Triceratops mit seinen drei Hörnern hat sich eigentlich gar nicht verteidigt, die waren nämlich hohl oder aus Pappmachee oder so und diese Hörner sind sofort abgebrochen und im Prinzip brauchten sie die gar nicht. Und man ist sich auch gar nicht mehr sicher, wie groß diese Hörner eigentlich waren. Man wisset auch gar nicht, ob es die überhaupt gegeben hat. Ciao! Tschüss! Und der zweite Fakt war, der T-Rex war wohlmöglich kein Jäger, sondern hat Ars gefressen. Und das war vorbei. Und ich sass da vor meinem Fernseher und meine Kinder sind echt in sich zusammengebrochen irgendwie. Alles, was ich gut fand und so. Dann habe ich meine Schleichs-Dinosaurier auch in Mülleimer geworfen. Aber ist es nicht eh so, dass die Dinosaurier eher so riesengroße Vögel waren und alle Federn hatten oder so? Da habe ich auch mal irgendwas gehört. Aber man ignoriert sowas auch einfach. Man hört so, übrigens, man hat jetzt rausgefunden, Dinosaurer hatten Federn, also ja, eigentlich nicht wirklich so, eigentlich nicht. Es kann perfekt bewiesen sein, es kann der beste, der beste Professor gewesen sein, das rausgefunden hat, der beste Paläontologe, einfach
nee, bevor ich mir
ein neues Sticker-Album kauf,
nee, eigentlich nicht.
Nein.
Wird einfach nicht angenommen, einfach der Wissenschaftler
hat einfach verzweifelt, es wird einfach nicht angenommen
von Öffentlichkeit. Ich glaube auch, dass viele wissenschaftliche Dinge
nicht angenommen werden, weil manche Dinge
einfach so cool sind, also die
Saurier waren einfach so cool, wie wir jetzt, dieser Stand,
der Wissensstand ist so cool, wir wollen den nicht überholen.
Wir wollen diesen Wissensstand nicht irgendwie,
... nicht angenommen werden, weil manche Dinge einfach so cool sind. Also die Saure waren einfach so cool, wie wir jetzt, dieser Stand, der Wissensstand ist so cool, wir wollen den nicht überholen. Wir wollen diesen Wissensstand nicht irgendwie optimieren. Nein, das ist genau perfekt so. Ja, der dreht sich um die Sonne. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt so... Also was wir vorher gesagt haben, war schon cooler. Das war schon cooler. Ja, genau. Also würde ich auch mal wünschen, dass Dinge passieren, einfach damit es cooler ist irgendwie? Ich habe mir sehr lange gewünscht, dass Griechenland aus dem Euro fliegt. Einfach damit mal was Interessantes passiert. Ja, oder jetzt auch mit der Legalisierung der Schwulen eher irgendwie. Ich dachte, da gäbe es noch irgendwie so Bürgerkrieg irgendwie, weil ich meine, jetzt irgendwie Sklaverei hat eben nicht. Die Schwulen gegen die Heteros, auf der Strasse rennen sie mit Riesenarmeen ineinander rein. Ja, damals Sklaverei irgendwie, das hat einen ganzen Bürgerkrieg gedauert, damit man das mal gelöst hat. Und Schwulen eher so nebenbei so, okay, dann. Ja, dann gibt es eine Spiegel-Online-Meldung, alle akzeptieren es plötzlich sofort. Ja, genau. Und ich finde, ja, ist ja auch alles korrekt und so, also nicht falsch verstehen, aber man wünscht sich halt, dass mehr passiert. Ich wünsche mir auch, dass Griechenland es allen gut geht und dass sie in Euro bleiben oder keine Ahnung, je nachdem, was am besten für sie ist, muss man halt abwägen, ist komplex. Aber ich wünsche mir trotzdem so, mein innerer Schweinehund wünscht sich, dass mehr passiert. Ja, absolut. Einfach damit was los ist. Es ist wieder so eine langweilige Serie irgendwie, wo man sagt, Leute, lasst euch doch mal was einfallen. Lasst Son Snow endlich mal sterben. Aber ist das eigentlich gut? Also jetzt geschichtlich gesehen, ist es gut, wenn es langweilig ist? Eigentlich nicht. Immer als es langweilig wurde, ist danach irgendwas Grosses passiert. Oder vielleicht auch nicht, ich weiß es nicht, ich mache mir Hoffnung. Keine Ahnung. Aber in Serien ist es so, dass wenn lange nichts passiert, dann denkt man, okay, jetzt muss was kommen und dann kommt auch was auf. Ein Lehrer von mir hat immer gesagt, dass das Leben wie eine Welle ist und wie eine so eine wellenförmige Kurve. Wenn man nicht am Meer lebt, hat man echt ein Problem. Genau, das war die Künnesenz. Das war auch eigentlich Immobilienmarkler. Ja und Stefan, du bist eher so ein Wüstentier. Und in der Wüste gibt es auch Wellen eigentlich, also so Semiwellen. Ja, komm schon. Ja, komm, scheiße auf, eigentlich nicht. Nein, nur nicht, eigentlich nicht. Ihr Frauen können auch wählen, naja, eigentlich nicht, nee, komm, eigentlich nicht. Ja, Trends, Trends ist ein gutes Thema, ne Florentin? Ja, Trends, und zwar, es gibt ja immer so Stereotypen, so Vorurteile, ne, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie als Stand-up-Kombi oder so möchtest du jemanden als Öko-Begeisterten zeichnen, dann hat der Sandalen an, ne, also so klassische Symbole, die man benutzt, um Vorteile darzustellen.
Ja.
Und in Amerika ist es zum Beispiel so, dass wenn man so diese Hipster-Öko-Hippie-Neu-Hippie-Kultur darstellen will, dann macht man das mit Bäumen?
Nein, mit Almond-Milk, mit Mandelmilch. Die trinken alle Mandelmilch. Das ist so ein bisschen so der Stereotyp, so von wegen, ah, da beim Starbucks irgendwie der Hipster Depp irgendwie nimmt dann noch mit Mandelmilch. Und ich dachte mir, anstatt sich da immer drüber lustig zu machen, probiere ich das diese Woche mal aus und habe mir Mandelmilch gekauft tatsächlich. Und ich habe auch gehört, das ist total gesund, kann man super damit abnehmen, hat keine Kalorien. Und das ist tatsächlich so,
wenn man
Mandelmich, es schmeckt tatsächlich nach Mandel, das ist ein bisschen
weird einfach, aber
es ist tatsächlich der Vorteil.
Die Marzipan so ein bisschen so, ne?
Ja, nein.
Der Vorteil ist auch so ein bisschen,
dass einem den ganzen Tag so ein bisschen
schlecht ist, so dass man gar keine
Lust hat, was zu essen und dadurch tatsächlich
abnimmt. Also ich habe jetzt tatsächlich abgenommen.
Echt? Von gestern.
Er hat auch so ein bisschen, dass einem den ganzen Tag so ein bisschen schlecht ist, so dass man gar keine Lust hat, was zu essen und dadurch tatsächlich abnimmt.
Also ich habe jetzt tatsächlich abgenommen.
Echt? Von gestern habe ich so 40 Gramm abgenommen oder sowas
in der Art. Von daher
kann ich das nur empfehlen. Mandelmilch für Leute,
die abnehmen wollen, haut rein.
Aber ich gucke ja immer gerne
diese US-Serie Shark Tank.
Kennst du die? Ja.
Also die gucke ich wirklich gerne, das ist eine Serie.
Wo schaust du die denn an eigentlich?
Internet kann man sich die angucken.
Das ist nicht mal so eine Serie, junge Start-Upper kommen halt da hin und stellen ihre Business-Ideen, pitchen die vor.
Grossen Investoren, die haben alle Geld und möglicherweise kaufen die sich Anteile in der Firma, um das zu unterstützen, manchmal auch nicht.
Und da hat auch ein Unternehmen, hat mal Almond Water vorgeschlagen, als Unternehmensidee.
Die haben wir jetzt noch nicht mehr, nur Mandelwasser, Marzipan-mäßiges Mandelwasser am Start gehabt. Schwommen dann so vier Mandeln drin in der Wasserfläche. Diese Serie ist aber auch relativ lustig. Da war nämlich einmal einer einem, der Luft, irgendwie so diese länglichen Luftballons, die man für Kinder so falten kann, ne? Die man so zerknoten kann und für Kinder dann irgendwie aufbereiten kann, damit es Hunde draus werden und alles sieht irgendwie aus wie ein Hund, aber es soll eine Giraffe sein und so. Und diese Dinger. Mach mal einen Wurm, mach mal eine Schlange. Ja, genau. Und der, und der, ja, dann müssen die auch mal sagen, ja, wie viele hast du den verkauft und wie läuft's denn so und gab's Probleme und er hat wirklich ein Problem aufgeführt, er hat gesagt, ja, er ist relativ weit, aber ganz ernst hat er gesagt, ja, er ist relativ weit zurück, er wurde zurückgeworfen im letzten Jahr die Clowns-Lobby hat ihn beschuldigt und er hat ihn irgendwie ins Gefecht gezogen. Und da war einfach so eine Clown-Lobby in Amerika, die den voll fertig gemacht hat, weil die halt irgendwie so das Monopol haben auf diese Dinger, auf diese grossen wurmmäßigen Luftballons. Ich glaube, wenn man sich mit einer Lobby nicht anlegen will, dann mit der fucking Clown-Lobby, weil die machen nicht fertig. Wie kommen die dann an und ich glaube, die bewerfen dann das Haus mit Torten. Ich glaube, da kommt erst mal ein so kleines Auto an, wo dann hundert Clowns
aussteigen, dann bewerfen sie ein Haus mit Torten oder
irgendwie so. Mit Torten und dann haben die diese
Blüge, wo Wasser rausspritzt und das ganze
Haus ist voller Wasser und Torten. Ja, Mandelwasser, ja.
Ach, genau.
Aber das fand ich sehr lustig, war ein sehr witziger Moment.
Ich glaube, das ist die härteste Lobby, die es gibt.
Clowns. Ja, viel darüber kommt glaube ich nicht.
Nee. Faultiere, Clowns. Hast du mal überlegt, Clown zu machen? Ich finde, Clowns ist ja ein schwieriges Thema, so ein bisschen. Ich finde, Clowns sind ja auch nicht wirklich lustig. Also die sind ja einfach nur da, um sich lustig zu machen. So ein bisschen wie du in der achten Klasse irgendwie. Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum ich jetzt da wieder drauf zu sprechen kommen muss. Ich dachte, das Thema haben wir beschlossen. Gibt es bei dir manchmal so Gags, die du immer wieder machst, obwohl sie niemand versteht? Wo du einfach sagst, bei dem Gag ist es mir jetzt egal, ob den jemand versteht oder nicht? Ja, das denke ich mir immer, wenn ich eine Geschichte erlebt habe. Und dann treffe ich mich danach mit Leuten und danach mit anderen Leuten. Und immer wieder bringe ich diese Geschichte, weil ich denke, sie wäre lustig. Und das erste Mal lacht keiner. Dann denke ich mir beim zweiten Mal, jetzt bringst du sie erst recht nochmal. Ja, einfach um uns den Ersten zu zeigen, dass ich mich nicht von ihrer Meinung beeinflusst. Genau, es nagt nämlich, mit Sicherheit lag es an den Leuten und nicht an deiner Geschichtserzählweise. Und deshalb hat wieder keiner gelacht. Und beim dritten Mal lasse ich es dann irgendwann auch einfach sein. Aber irgendwann lernt man halt daraus und du nicht wahrscheinlich. Es gibt manche Gags, die finde ich tatsächlich okay und die mache ich immer wieder, obwohl sie niemand checkt. Und zwar immer, wenn ich Leute treffe, die irgendwie einen Social-Media-Account haben, wo sie ein Profilbild haben, das nicht sie sind. Also irgendwie ein Sonnenuntergang oder eine Palme oder ein Hund oder sowas. Denn immer wenn ich sie treffe, sage ich, oh Mensch, du siehst ja überhaupt nicht so aus wie auf deinem Profilbild. Und ich kriege immer dieselbe Reaktion, so, hä, wie? Ja, Leute, checkt eure verdammten Profilbilder. Ja, einfach ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit. Ja, genau. Aber das ist echt ein Problem, dass Leute, die Leute rechnen bei dem ersten Kontakt selten mit Gags. Ja. Das ist tatsächlich ein riesiges Problem. Und deswegen denken arrogante Leute wie ich auch immer, die Leute wären nicht lustig und hätten keinen Humor. Aber es stimmt wahrscheinlich eigentlich nicht, sondern die Leute rechnen einfach nicht damit. Ne, genau. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn sie wissen, dass du in der Comedy-Branche arbeitest, wenn sie das wissen, wo du aber nicht weißt, ob sie es wissen, dann erwarten sie sofort, dass du unfassbar lustig bist. Das stimmt, was man dann auch wieder nicht erfüllen kann. Und dann erwarten sie nämlich auch Gags zum Anfang, die du aber, weil du empirischerweise durchs Leben rennst, gelernt hast, dass du das nicht machen solltest und deswegen bist du automatisch der Unlustige. Ist halt so. Okay, aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, ehrlicherweise, du hast ja einen ziemlich coolen Job. Also du hast ja einen Job, den viele Leute als … Du meinst meinen Pizza-Austrag-Job. Genau. Du hast ja einen Job, irgendwie die Zeitung zu verteilen. Du hast ja einen Job, den viele Leute als Traumjob bezeichnen würden. Ja, im Phantasialand darf ich die Black Mamba einfahren, ja. Wie nutzt du das bei sozialen Gelegenheiten? Versuchst du das ins Gespräch mit einzubringen, dass du sagst, hey, diese schwarze Schlange, wie heißt die nochmal, habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen, also versuchst du das dann direkt konfrontativ, aggressiv?
Ich muss schon sagen, ich bin da sehr konfrontiert, sehr angriffslustig.
Zum Beispiel versuche ich auch, egal wo das Thema gerade ist, das Thema dahin zu lenken.
Also wir reden gerade über Lampen und so.
Ja, wir haben auch in unserem Redaktionsraum im Neo Magazin eine tolle Lampe stehen.
Ich weiss nicht. Egal, wo das Thema gerade ist, das Thema dahin zu lenken. Also wir reden gerade über Lampen und so. Ja, wir haben auch in unserem Redaktionsraum im Neo Magazin eine tolle Lampe stehen.
Ich weiss nicht.
Also, ja, dann bin ich halt da.
So, das ist meine Masche eigentlich.
Ich versuche möglichst schnell das Thema dahin zu lenken,
um möglichst damit dann alle Bescheid wissen und ich meine dämlichen Gags machen kann.
Aber die Leute erwarten natürlich auch sehr gute Gags.
Wie gesagt, da schneidet man sich wieder ins eigene Fleisch. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Man sollte das wahrscheinlich erst am Ende des Abends sagen,
damit alle Leute denken, ah, das war
ja alles lustig, und dann
trotzdem noch mit dir schlafen wollen.
Ja, genau.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt, sollte man was machen.
Wird das schon wieder eine dieser Folgen? Sind wir jetzt schon wieder im Rausschneidemodus? Sind wir jetzt in dieser Abyssartigen Schwebe, wo man eh weiss, dass es später rausgeschnitten wird? Nee, pass auf. Sind das die Momente, wo man wirklich Ehrlichkeit durchkommt, wo der echte Stefan Titzel mit seiner echten Frustration, seiner echten Wut und seinen echten Gefühlen mal durchblitzt? Ist das einer dieser Momente, wo wir ihn haben, wo er am Punkt der Schwäche angekommen ist, wo seine ganze Schlagfälligkeit, sein Sarkasmus und sein Sprechtraining versagt? Wo mal wirklich der echte Mensch durchkommt? Und in dem Moment klingelt sein T-Defon. Das ist auch ein unfassbar hässlicher Klingelton, aber ich weiss noch nicht, wie ich das so ausstellen kann. Ich habe das noch nicht hinbekommen, dass es ein anderer Klingelton irgendwie ist. Hör dir das mal an. Das ist auch so ein bisschen melancholisch irgendwie. Man will gar nicht drangehen, weil es so ein trauer Klingelton ist. Der Tod ruft an, ja. Gott, was für ein trauer Klingelton ist. Oh na, hallo? Ich finde auch, Klingelton in Moll sollten eigentlich verboten werden. Du bist nicht angegangen einfach. Nein, natürlich nicht. Ich muss mal kurz jemandem beschreiben, dass ich nicht ans Telefon gehen kann. Aber das war jetzt dein Handy oder was? Nee, mein Festnetz. Warum hast du denn überhaupt eine Festnetz? Weil ich hier so ein Paket gekauft habe mit Internet und Internetfernsehen und da ist halt auch Festnetz dabei. War auch niemand, aber ist da kostenlos dabei. Und wem hast du denn die Nummer gegeben? Nur meine Eltern besitzen diese Nummer. Ja. Das heißt, deine Eltern haben gerade versucht, dich zu erreichen und du hast ihnen ganz knallhart Kommunikation verwehrt. Ich wollte dir kurz... Tante Erna könnte gestorben sein, der Klingelton hat auch schon einiges verraten. Wie gut wäre, wenn der Klingelton schon verrät, was im Gespräch gleich passiert. Ja genau, die Stimme schon analysiert von dem Gegenüber und dann den Klingelton anpasst. Das wäre echt grossartig, wenn man vorher irgendwie eine Zahl drücken muss und die Stimmung dadurch angeben muss und dann der Klingelton verrät, was passiert ist. Zum Beispiel Todesfall, zum Beispiel Kind wird geboren. Kind ist gestorben. Kind ist, oh Gott. Oh Gott. Ja, Entschuldigung. Sorry. So, ich bin jetzt wieder am Start. Ich habe allen gesagt, dass man mich ehrlich erreichen kann gerade, weil ich in einer wichtigen Aufnahmesituation mich befinde. Trends. Okay, ganz kurz, kommen wir jetzt wieder zurück aus dem abyssartigen Schwebezustand. Okay. Und wir sind back on air in drei, zwei. Nostalgie. Nostalgie ist ja auch so ein Thema. Ich habe in der Tat noch was nicht untergebracht letzte Woche. Da wollte ich noch was erzählen und zwar von meinem Podcast-UFO-Nachtrag. Ja, genau. Und zwar wollte ich noch von meinem Radio erzählen. Ich habe nämlich aus irgendwie so nostalgischen Gründen habe ich mir so ein altes Radio für mein Badezimmer gekauft, sondern so ein kleines Radio, das man da hinstellt und wo man noch die Antenne rausfahren muss und so noch per Hand einstellen muss, den Sender noch einstellen muss, die Frequenz suchen muss.
Und das Ding ist, dass es echt scheisse nervig ist und ich wünschte, ich hätte das nicht einfach.
Also ich finde es, ich verbringe relativ viel Zeit. Kategorie Fehlkauf, Fragezeichen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Morgens verbringe ich immer sehr viel Zeit in meinem Bad, wie jeder Mensch halt.
Man positioniert, man duscht und dann hat man halt, ich habe dann halt gerne Musik im Hintergrund oder irgendwie so eine Stimme, die das erzählt. Aber leider ist es echt die falsche Wahl gewesen, weil zum einen, man muss zum Beispiel, man muss nämlich jeden Morgen neu den Sender suchen. So, dass es aber so manuell ist, kann es sich eigentlich gar nicht, es kann sich nicht verschieben. Also es kann sich nicht verschieben, der Sender.
Und wenn die Sender nicht jeden Tag
eine neue Frequenz haben, aus irgendeinem Grund,
weiß ich nicht, woran das liegt, aber jeden Morgen muss man
einen neuen Sender einstellen,
weil irgendwie Rausch ist plötzlich.
Dann hat man den Sender gefunden, dann
Rausch ist nicht mehr, dann geht man einen Schritt
nach rechts und es rauscht wieder.
Also die Antenne muss man so schieben,
halt muss man richtig in Richtung Fenster schieben, aber dann muss man selber auch so vorm Radio stehen, dass es empfangbar ist, der Sender. Weil sobald du weggehst, geht es nicht mehr. Dann manchmal unter der Dusche, aus unerfindlichen Gründen, plötzlich stehe ich dann so, dass das Radio auf einmal unfassbar laut wird, dass der Sender plötzlich so gut empfangbar ist, dass es unfassbar laut wird. Und dann kann es mal vorkommen, dass es irgendwie um sieben Uhr morgens, weil ich früh zur Uni muss, irgendwie unfassbar laut rebuild this city durch das Haus schallt, was einfach nur unfassbar unerträglich ist, ich dann so früh morgens im Schlaf trunken zum Radio eilen muss und ausmachen muss. Es ist einfach nur furchtbar, es hat nur Nachteile dieses Scheißding. Ich weiß nicht, was ich hier machen soll. Vom Dämonen besessene Radio-Teil. Einfach überflüssig, einfach du hast 14.000 Euro dafür ausgegeben, das ist ja endlich angeschafft. Das ist der einzige Aspekt, wo ich sagen muss, okay, das war's. Ich glaube, ich könnte mir nie teure Dinge kaufen, weil ich mir immer denken würde, das ist es doch nicht wert.
Ich glaube, ich könnte mir nie irgendwie ein Auto kaufen oder irgendwie eine teure Kaffeemaschine oder so.
Also fernab davon, dass ich keinen Bedarf von einer Kaffeemaschine habe.
Oh shit, ich habe noch meinen Tee.
Oh fuck, warte, ich komme gleich.
Ja, hol den mal kurz.
Hol den mal kurz.
Ich wette, es lag nämlich daran.
We bet the city. Jetzt hol den mal kurz. Ich wette, es lag nämlich daran. We built the city, we built the city of rock and roll, built the city, we built the city, we built the city of rock and roll, built the city! We built this city of rock'n'roll, built this city.
We built this city of rock'n'roll, built this city.
Hey!
Yay.
So, da bin ich, ach shit, jetzt habe ich mir auch mein T-Shirt. Was hast du dir für einen Tee gemacht in so unserer schönen Folge, Leute? Ich habe tatsächlich, also ich weiss nicht, ob das zu wahnsinnig ist. Hast du in echten Folge 25 Tee? Hm. Ich habe Chaiti, ich habe jetzt wahnsinnig viel Chaiti gekauft. Ich weiss nicht, ob mal in so einem hippen, angesagten Zähnlokalen stehen diese verschiedenfarbigen Chai-Tea-Zylinder herum.
Nee, doch Zylinder. Ich verwechsel immer
Zylinder und Kegel. Kleiner
Math-Fact.
Und die habe ich mir jetzt auch gekauft, ganz viele verschiedene
Sorten und jetzt trinke ich ganz viel Chai-Tea.
So, das ist jetzt mein neues. Ich habe grüner Tee-Zitrone
mir heute mal gemacht. Und ich denke,
das merkt man auch. Ich finde, unsere Hörer sind
irgendwann an dem Punkt, wo sie eine Folge hören und dadurch sagen können, was für einen Tee wir getrunken haben. Ich finde, ich war heute die ganze Zeit in so einer grünen Tee Zitrone. Ja, ein bisschen entspannt, aber irgendwie ein bisschen frech aufgeregt, spritzig, irgendwie sauer. Genau. Und du warst bislang, bislang hast du gar nicht stattgefunden. Und ab jetzt, aber jetzt gucken wir mal, wie ein Schei-Tee. Ja, ja, ab jetzt wird sich knackig arabisch-leidenschaftliche, feurige,
Arabisch, fängt es plötzlich an, hier irgendwie hebräisch zu sprechen.
Entschuldigung.
Soll ich keine Gags mehr machen? Tut mir leid. Ja, hallo?
Nee, keine Araber-Gags mehr, irgendwie too soon.
Or too early.
Too soon, ich habe es gemacht, bevor etwas hat passiert. Viel too soon. Ach, komm. Ach, komm schon, ey. Ja. Okay, also, wir haben auch eine neue Rubrik mit, nee, komm, das machen wir jetzt nochmal neu. Das nicht, hier schneiden wir. Machen wir einen guten Scheite-Gag-Rauskomma. Jetzt schneiden. Okay. Scheite-Gag-Rauskomma. Das ist schon eine sehr spezielle Anforderung hier. Wir brauchen jetzt einen Scheite-Rauskomma, neun Sekunden lang. Wir können ja auch mal ausfaden oder wieder einfaden, so als hätten wir gerade irgendwie, wären wir im Zeittunnel oder so gefangen. Ich wäre gerne mal im Zeittunnel gefangen. Was glaubst du, welche, gibt es eine Familienkonstellation, die sich noch nicht getötet hat? Also zum Beispiel, ich glaube der Satz, meine Oma hat meine andere Oma getötet, wird relativ selten gesagt. Glaubst du, es gibt eine Konstellation, die noch nie stattgefunden hat? Mein Cousin
hat mich
umgebracht. Kommt relativ selten
vor, glaube ich. Meinst du?
Ich glaube, Leute werden häufig von ihren Cousins
umgebracht. Ja, aber ich glaube, man ist
dann noch nicht mehr in der Lage, das zu sagen.
Deswegen, glaube ich, wurde das relativ selten
gesagt. Cousins sind auch seltsam.
Cousins ist eine ganz komische Geschichte. Sag doch mal Cousins. Cousin oder Cousin oder wie du mit deinem scheiss pedantischen Sprechtraining. Keine Ahnung, wie das gesprochen wird. Vor allem, wer sagt denn, wie was richtig ausgesprochen wird? Es wird so ausgesprochen, wie es die Mehrheit sagt. Das ist genauso wie diese Scheiss-Debatten von wegen, ob man jetzt Machtsinn oder Ägyptensinn sagt. Wenn man das halt so sagt, dann wird das halt so gesagt. Punkt. Da bin ich jetzt mal auf der Seite des Volkes. Sehr gut. Bin ich selten, aber bei der Diskussion bin ich's. Sehr gut. Du, wir wollen heute mal eine neue Rubrik starten. Und zwar haben jeder von uns, hat sich drei Gags ausgedacht, die zu Florentins typischem Twitter-Duktus
passen. Und zwar haut er manchmal so Gags raus im Sinne von anonymer Alkoholiker-Clubs. Und das kann man wesentlich besser anmoderieren. Ich weiß keine Ahnung, ob ich den Bogen schlagen soll. Ich weiß nicht, wie man diese Rubrik irgendwie in Worte fassen soll. Vielleicht sollen wir einfach das Intro spielen.
Club Sandwich.
Wir sind gespannt.
Club Sandwich heißt die Rubrik und in der versuchen wir jede Woche eine gewisse Gag-Struktur zu erfüllen mit drei verschiedenen Beispielen. Und der jeweils beste der drei Gags wird veröffentlicht als Tweet und die Erlöser aus diesem Tweet gehen direkt an die Spendenstiftung Namibia für afrikanische Kinder. An die SOS-Kinderdörfer. Genau. Also. Ja, los geht's. Und das Format für diese Woche ist der Club-Gag. Wir müssen, glaube ich, erst mal das Prinzip eines Club-Gags erklären. Hast du ein Beispiel? Ja, das klassische Beispiel... Ist das richtig? Bist du so schlecht vorbereitet, dass du das Beispiel als Gag benutzt hast? Das ist aber echt schwer zu erklären. Ich glaube, die Rubrik besteht zu 90 Prozent daraus. Versuchen zu erklären. Vielleicht moderieren wir einfach nochmal neu an. Okay. In der Rubrik Club Sandwich geht es darum, dass wir jede Woche versuchen, ein, naja, Gag-Format, ein Gag-Muster zu erfüllen mit drei verschiedenen Beispielen. Und das jeweils beste Beispiel von jedem wird dann veröffentlicht als Tweet und die Erlöse aus dem Tweet gehen direkt an die SOS-Kinderhilfe. Und die Struktur, die wir uns heute ausgesucht haben. Das bringt auch gleich so eine richtige Schärfe da rein. Das bringt gleich so eine totaler Ernst. Die Struktur, die wir uns heute ausgesucht haben, ist die des Clubwitzes.
Wie gesagt, Gags basieren oft darauf, was Leute schon wissen. Und in Club-Situationen, also anonyme Alkoholiker, Selbsthilfegruppe, da gibt es bestimmte Sätze, die fallen, bestimmte Rituale, die fallen, und die versucht man eben aufzugreifen und humoristisch aufzulösen. Wie zum Beispiel der Satz, ich sehe hier eine Menge neuer Gesichter, wird häufig gesagt in solchen Sätzen, also wenn der Held in der Serie zu den anonymen Alkoholikern geht, dann sagt er, herzlich willkommen an anonymen Alkoholikern, ich sehe hier eine Menge neuer Gesichter. So, wie kann man diesen Satz humoristisch auflösen? Wir schauen uns ein Beispiel an, das kommt von einem sehr talentierten Nachwuchskomedien namens Florentin Will aus dem Jahre 2015 und er geht folgendermassen. Herzlich willkommen im Vermummungsclub, ich sehe eine Menge neuer Gesichter, ihr seid im falschen Raum. Sie hörten ein Beispiel eines Club-Gags von Florentin Sebastiano Will. Ich finde eigentlich, du solltest dich Florentin möchte nennen. So, und zwar, also jeder von uns stellt jetzt quasi drei Gags vor und wir nehmen dann den besten oder und wir nehmen dann den besten und stellen dann das Internet rein. Ja, so könnte man das vor 15 Jahren formuliert haben. Wir stellen das in das Internet rein. Ja, okay, können wir gerne machen, Opa. Wir laden es aufwendig in das Internet hoch. Wir stellen es in das Internet rein. Das ist schon sehr schön. Ja, ja, genau.
Okay, also. Soll ich mal den Start machen?
Ja, mach, nee, ja, na.
Okay, mach du den Start, mach du den Start.
Nee, mach du den Start, ich habe nämlich nur zwei, dann können wir das gut umpacken.
Nee, das ist nicht, du hast jetzt schon den Weg verloren.
Nee, ich habe heute schon den Beispielsatz gemacht.
Im Club der anonymen Objektophilen. Ist der Stuhl da frei? Nein, der hat einen Freund. Du musst ja echt lachen, das wird echt furchtbar. Okay, dann machen wir gleich weiter mit dem zweiten Beispiel. Dieser Gag enthält wörtliche Rede. Ich werde diese damit andeuten, dass ich die wörtliche Rede mit einer anderen, eventuell humoristisch angehauchten Stimme in einem Dialekt, sprich in Norddeutsch. Nein, Dialekte sind nicht lustig. Nee, stimmt gar nicht, es sagt alles nur eine Figur. Sie hören Beispielwitz. Sie hören, wie man Anmoderation macht, von der Frank-Elzner-Moderationsschule mit Florentin Mächte. Sie hören jetzt Beispielwitz Nummer zwei, erneut von Florentin Will aus dem Jahre 2015. Herzlich willkommen im Dinge zu wörtlich nehmen Club. Nehmen Sie Platz. Nein, gebt ihn wieder her. Los, ihm hinterher. Sie hörten Beispiel zwei von Flo, den Wettel aus dem Jahre 2015. Es folgt ein humoristischer Beitrag des Comedians Stefan Tietze aus dem Jahre 2015. Ähm, Schmidt, bin ich hier richtig im Club der schlechten Wahrsager? Ach, Herr Schmidt, mit Ihnen haben wir heute noch gar nicht gerechnet. So, Entschuldigung mal, das ist wirklich kein schlechter Gag. Und dass du jetzt mit so viel Schweigen gestrafstrafst, finde ich auch echt. Sie hatten einen humoristischen Beitrag von Stefan Titzer aus dem Jahr 2015. Ja, und wo ist dein Dritter jetzt? Sie hören nun Beispiel Nummer zwei des humoristisch Humorkünstlers des Humorjongleurs, Florentin Will aus dem Jahre 2015, geschrieben in Berlin, Deutschland. Herzlich willkommen im Club der Fallensteller. Nehmt ihr euch doch schon mal von den Donuts, während ich mir mal den Laubhaufen da hinten ansehe. Das war ein Beispiel des humoristischen Humor-Akrobaten Florentin Will. Kommen wir nun zu einem erneuten humoristisch-spritzig-peckigen, Pepping, Entschuldigen Sie bitte, Pepping, Beitrag von Stefan Tiziorzo, einem spanischen Nachwuchskomedien, der mit seinen feurigen Pointen das Publikum zum Beben bringt. Hier eine kleine Kostprobe. Das ist jetzt beides Mal, ist das jetzt quasi in eckigen Klammern, und bei beiden Mal möchte ich als Künstler die Situation darstellen als Regieanweisung. Achtung. Im Club der anonymen Orientierungslosen. Nichts, niemand hat den Raum gefunden. Ein kleiner Nachtrag zu diesem humoristisch spritzigen Witzchen, eine Variante, Variante 1, gelesen, von Florenton Will, in eckigen Anführungszeichen, der Club, nee, wir formulieren es anders, Club Seminar für fortgeschrittenes Zeitmanagement, darunter zu lesen in eckigen Klammern, niemand, die Teilnehmer haben, den Termin verpasst. Das war eine Variante in Gedur unseres Künstlers Florentin Wiel aus der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Das war der Beitrag der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Es folgt Israel mit der Statua.
Doch bevor wir uns nach Israel wenden, folgt noch ein weiterer humoristisch lustiger Beitrag zum Wohle der Kinderkrebshilfe Deutschland von Florentin Will. Was, wieso hast du plötzlich vier? Bitte bleiben Sie dran. Bitte bleiben Sie sitzen.
Dieser Beitrag wird Ihnen gesponsert von den Bangladesch Minenkindern, einer Organisation, die sich für von Minenunglücken verstümmelte Kinder einsetzt. Bitte bleiben Sie dran.
Herzlich willkommen zum Club der anonymen Narzissten. Ihr freut euch, mich zu sehen.
Sie hörten einen Beitrag der Kinderkrebsnothilfe. Bitte spenden Sie zahlreiche an die ... Oh Gott. Die Kinder werden es ihnen danken. Das war unsere Rubrik Lockeres Lachen am Nachmittag. Also, welche hat dir am besten gefallen? Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen. Das war unsere Rubrik. Wir haben keinen Trainer. Florian, wir haben auch den Trainer.
Ich will auch niemals einen machen. Und wir werden da niemals einen einfügen. Also mein Lieblingsgag davon war, muss ich sagen, der Laubhaufen. Mir tatsächlich der Orientierungslosen am besten gefallen. Das heißt, wir hauen jetzt raus. Okay, ich bin gespannt. Wie kommt der an? Ich bin gespannt. Sie hörten innovative Überbrückungsmoderationen aus dem Handbuch, Moderieren für Anfänger und Fortgeschrittene von Stefan T. Nee, Moderation von Dummies für Dummies, will ich nennen. Im Club der anonymen Orientierungslosen nichts, niemand hat den Raum gefunden. Warte, aber ganz kurz, wir veröffentlichen gleichzeitig. Hab schon. Du musst also jetzt nicht weilen. Also ich lösche nicht nochmal. Ja, aber ganz genau, wo sind jetzt die Regeln bitte? Wenn du mehr Faves bekommst, ist das relativ wahrscheinlich, weil du halt auch wesentlich mehr Follower hast.
Also habe ich ehemals eine Chance, in diesem Spiel zu gewinnen.
Schreibt man da hinten zusammen?
Keine Ahnung.
Nein.
Meine Faves lassen doch auf sich warten.
Ich habe es gesagt und da kam schon einer. Okay, und der erste Fave kriegt einen Shoutout, würde ich sagen.
Mrs. Nimre kriegt einen Shoutout.
Das ist dein Shoutout, herzliche Glückwunsch. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, du bekommst einen Gutschein von der Krebshilfe Deutschland, der Kinderkrebshilfe Deutschland hat für dich zusammengelegt. Und bei mir ist es Hendrik. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Hendrik Hendrik! Woo! Du kriegst, anders als Mrs. Nimre, kriegst du von dem Kinderhospiz Neukölln ein Gutschein. Eine selbstgebastelte Wandinstallation, in der sie die Geschichte erzählen, wie sie in das Hospiz gekommen sind und was sie in Bangladesch erlebt haben. Ich muss sagen, ich finde es mittlerweile nicht so schlecht. wenn wir mal ein bisschen weniger machen. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel, wir haben jetzt 50 Minuten fast geredet, ich sag mal, nein, haben wir nicht. Ich sag mal, wir haben jetzt so ungefähr drei, vier Stunden geredet. Ich finde es nicht so schlimm, wenn wir dann einfach mal in diesem Moment immer aufhören und sagen, wir haben jetzt immer, wir hauen immer Folgen raus. Ist das jetzt ein persönliches Gespräch oder ist es noch Teil des Podcasts oder was? Es ist noch jetzt gerade, es ist auch immer bei uns nicht ganz imprenzierbar. Das ist so eine ernste Stimme, so, nee, Stefan, aber ganz kurz, wir müssen das echt mal ein bisschen überlegen, wie wir das mit der Website machen, weil das kann so nicht weitergehen. PHP 5.0, hallo, wir sehen ja nicht mehr 2014. Ne, um deiner Schwester, da ging echt nichts neulich, da ging echt nichts. Naja, nur weil sie deinen Tweet favorisiert, da heisst es nicht unbedingt was, ne?
Lass die Finger von ihr.
Nee,
ich finde es,
wollte ich damit sagen, nicht so schlecht, wenn wir mal, wenn wir einfach jetzt kürzere Folgen raus haben,
und dafür halt immer kontinuierlich
Gespräch aufrechterhalten.
Ja, finde ich gut.
Wir können auch zweimal die Folge machen. Fuck, ey, mich irritiert das ein bisschen, dass ich keine Faves kriege. Ich glaube, den Gag versteht man nicht. Ja, nee, aber das ist egal. Du hast jetzt absichtlich einen von mir genommen, den man nicht versteht, damit ich keine Faves kriege. Man muss weiterdenken. Ich wollte dich demütigen natürlich auch, in einem zweiten Schritt. Mir hat jemand geantwortet, puh, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Oh shit, ich kriege auch ein schlechtes Feedback. Ja, okay, ich glaube, das war keine so gute Idee. Du solltest ihn aber lassen, du solltest ihn da lassen.
Tut mir leid.
Du kannst ihn nicht lassen. Tut mir leid.
Ne, ne, ne.
Da ist die Podcast, ich bin nicht loyal dem Podcast Ufe gegenüber.
Ich bin sofort bereit, auf jedes andere sinkende Schiff zu springen, sobald sich die Gelegenheit ergibt. Das Podcastufe bedeutet mir gar nichts. Ja, ich lasse es mal so stehen. Ich finde den nämlich nicht so schlecht. Und ich hau relativ wenig raus bei Twitter, muss ich sagen, weil ich da nie daran denke. Ich lasse es mal so stehen und gucke mal, was passiert, ob Twitter ihn noch annimmt oder nicht. Du musst ja auch denken, das waren ja jetzt erst die Early Adopter, dann gibt es die Early Majority, die Late Majority und dann Folgen Leggets. Und bei dir haben die Opinionlieder zugebissen und bei mir nicht. Nächste Frage, ob Opinionlieder oder Multiplikatoren sogar zuschlagen. Wenn das so ist, dann naja, hat man schon gesagt, dass das Tweet auch durch die Decke geht. Ich wollte noch kurz mit meinem Pop-Schutz zur Liebe kurz noch mal wiederholen, was mir geantwortet wurde auf meinem Tweet. Puh, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, sehr gut. Puh, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Machst du mal? Puh, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Nein, du hast eine Socke, es klingt wesentlich besser. Es klingt wesentlich wolliger. Ähm. Also, Florentin ist komplett raus, aber Leute, ich bin noch da, keine Angst, wenn ihr uns gerade irgendwie hört, beim Schlafen gehen, zum Schlafen gehen oder so, und denkt ihr, jetzt hat Florentin euch verlassen.
Ja, aber ich bin noch da und ich bin auch noch in der Lage, eine Abmoderation zu machen.
Wow, Leute, was war das für eine Folge? Ich weiß es nicht, ihr fasst es nicht, Florentin fasst es nicht.
Aber ich hatte hier doch noch irgendwo ...
Ich sag nur, wow, wow, wow.
Ich hatte hier noch ...
... und ich schwebt rumliegen, warte mal.
Nee, ich hör dir schon zu, warte mal, mach mal ... Diese Woche vom Podcast. Ich mach nur ganz kurz. Bitte nicht. Wo hatte ich hier noch was? Da hab ich gestern schon rausgehauen, ne? Ja, vielen Dank, liebe Leute, fürs Zuhören. Wieder einmal haben wir euch über diese... Ach, forget it, ey. Ja, ich weiss nicht, du wirst da schon irgendwas Vernünftiges rausschneiden können, oder? Diese Folge ist nämlich in eine komische Richtung abgedriftet. Ja, ich weiss nicht genau, wie das passieren könnte. Ich glaube, er hat in der Mitte irgendwie mal die zwei, drei Anekdoten, die du erzählt hast, mit einem Pfirsichbaum sind ganz gut, den Rest musst du halt irgendwie schauen, dass du rausschneidest. Ich habe kurz vor der Folge entdeckt, dass ich einen Pfirsichbaum vor meiner Wohnung stehe. Pfirsich? Wie sagt man das? Wie nennt man das? Pfirsichbaum vor meiner Wohnung stehen habe. Vielen Dank, Florentin Will, für diese Anmerkung.
Was schätzt du, wie viel haben wir? 20 Minuten, wie viel haben wir heute? 18 Minuten?
Schneid es mal, raff das mal ein bisschen zusammen hier.
18 gute Minuten, aber das reicht uns diese Woche.
Also 25, Florentin Will und ich sollten das immer entschuldigen.
Sorry, Leute, I'm sorry.